so why do you continue to work out if
you haven't noticed any measurable
differences in in business well I don't
work out for business I think a lot
about being 90 to 100 I think about who
am I going to be at that point garyvee
today is trying to put out good into the
world and has a big platform well me a
90 to 100 I can be on some Yoda [ __ ] and
if I can hang for another 10 more years
I can leave more positive deposits and
if I have to do [ __ ] Bulgarian split
squats to be there then [ __ ] it I'm
going to do it so for this this episode
let's discuss your health and wellness
habits because I know that is something
that you're big on yes and a lot of
entrepreneurs and business owners is
this is something that they're severely
lacking yes and I was the far majority
of my career yeah so I work with a lot
of guys they've done very well for
themselves in business yes but they are
burning themselves out because they are
prioritizing the business over their own
personal health and happiness so how did
you first come to that realization I
wasn't burning myself out
I was sleeping plenty like I think the
big misnomers about me is that I'm so
passionate high energy that I think
people don't realize how many things
come to me naturally on the health and
wellness front
sleep I've always been a six seven eight
hour guy
um anxiety and pressure like I sleep
like a baby like literally
lights out
um but I was doing nothing on eating and
working out and at 38
um about 35 I started being like wait a
minute like I'm like a little much I'm
not a little I'm like there's some real
fluff here and so I started playing a
little bit with like exercising for the
first time in my life probably around 32
actually going back to Matt Matt if
you're out there hit me up brother I
miss you guy lived local basketball dude
treadmill first time I mean I had done
nothing like I was one of the back to
sports cards in high school I was a very
rare breed almost everybody I knew
outside of like seven or ten other dudes
like at least hit the weight room at
some point in high school because they
played a high school sport like I played
tennis so like we didn't have to do that
like I just never did anything I'd never
benched like I genuinely did nothing
yeah so at 32 was like the first time I
kind of hit the gym was super hard it
was like super sporadic I did very
little like I got hot for like two
months and then sure enough like nothing
then my career started really taking off
at 34 and 34 to 38 just so much travel
like it was just like it was just not in
the cards it didn't come natural to me I
didn't eat well I didn't work out at all
so at 38 even when I look at the content
now I'm like [ __ ] like it was really
starting to go down a direction that was
super obvious to me
even though my grandfather and my mom's
side who I'm more similar to past young
I got to see even though there was not a
lot of photos of him in Russia I got to
see like and look he had a very tough
life he'd spent 10 years in jail around
the anti-Semitism in Eastern Europe but
like even with all that said the body
type and then my uncle my mom's brother
who I'm I think I have more body type
similarities to he on the other hand has
really taken care of himself and like
Uncle Joseph at like
72 looks like a [ __ ] like looks great
I'm like wait a minute like that makes
more sense for me to go down that path
so
I just started having realizations that
this isn't good
like just a very logical practical convo
like you're having right now of like I'm
not prioritizing this this does not come
natural to me
oh my God I'm giving really good advice
to people about business that's based on
like very basic principles and I can't
take that in health and wellness like
get in the gym and and eat properly and
like good things will happen and so I
kind of started selling myself on this
put out a Facebook fan page post of like
I need someone this guy John Won he
worked me out for a while
that was an okay run at like 35 36 37
like I almost got there I got in the gym
a little bit more he was a fun character
he had like a business and like so it
was like fun for me a little bit to talk
to him it was like almost like I was
Consulting while I was working out it
was fun
then again just it wasn't a real
commitment he then
uh introduced me to a kid Mike vacanti
Mike who has stuck and more people know
that are my world he was my trainer for
six months and I worked out like six
times in six months I canceled like 47
times like and so why because I just
wasn't coming you know and you know this
either you're in or you're out there is
no half pregnant no not on business not
on on health and wellness not on
anything like you're just either in or
you're out it's just binary and so I was
half like I was trying but it came so
not natural I didn't like it
six months later after like lollygagging
with him for a couple months and then
not talking to him for three months I
called him
I said Mike on my 40th birthday
I was on a pla I told him a story I was
on a plane I remember like yesterday I'm
literally in the first row because I
remember the feet right head on the
thing tired flew into Dallas flying back
you know
and I'm just like
on my 40th birthday I'm going for it I'm
30 and a half
talk like seven thirty and a half
and
I'm going to spend the next year and a
half getting myself mentally in to
commit to this thing by the time the
plane is in the air because it's on the
ground by the time it just like lifts
off not like I had already committed
I've already committed to 39. yeah I'm
like what the [ __ ] am I waiting to 44.
yeah by the time I land
I text Mike do you have a moment to talk
I go Mike and I figured it out from that
Dallas flight home that what makes me me
professionally is I love being a leader
I like delivering for Andrew and Dustin
Jake like I like delivering for them
what I what was making me not win health
and wellness was I'm not good
challenging myself or myself doing it
for myself
so I figured this thing out where I was
like if I could be held accountable to a
babysitter
if I don't let Mike down if I'm doing it
for Mike
maybe this will work so this hypothesis
that if I did it for someone else it
would work
and I finally got to the financial place
where I could hire somebody full-time to
follow me around I wanted to be
suffocated
so I called Mike I said Mike you're my
last trainer like do you know somebody
who's like a little younger than you who
is at that point in their life like you
know 1922 24 year old dude who can just
like [ __ ] live with me travel with me
um you know like you know like do
something like that and he said what
about me and I said are you there
because he was you know Mike was like 25
or seven at the time I just he had all
these clients in an online business and
I wasn't sure he could he's like I can
do it we talked it through a couple
weeks later he started and from that day
to this day besides a three-year period
where his friend Jordan did it Mike has
been my full-time trainer he moved to
Minnesota full time during covid and so
we do it virtually now which is a little
more of a challenge for me like it flies
in occasionally we do it and I'm like
there's a little bit of a difference and
so I've been thinking through that
lately he doesn't travel with me as much
but
since I was 38 and a half uh and now I
just I turned 47 so nine years
um I've been doing it and it's
completely changed my life so Jordan
changed my soft tissue part of my life
so that fixed my back
um my strength is dramatically higher my
eating habits are much stronger I
continue to be more and more educated
with that in my life and so I'm I'm
really happy I did it how does the
strength aspect of it and your back
feeling better and everything that goes
along with consistent workouts how is
that showing up for you in the business
world like what's the difference between
and I say that with like a funny answer
because I don't like making things up
I believe that it has helped so many of
my friends the amount of friends that
say to me because when I did it
a lot of my friends who are like in
better shape than me were like [ __ ] this
you're getting better than me like I'm
gonna do it too like Mike Lazaro big
shout out like a lot of my friends like
took up on it and for a lot of them it
did impact it I don't know if I
I can tell you without a shadow of a
doubt I'm sure there's some impacts
because I would like to not dismiss it
but I want to be unbelievably
transparent I don't have any extra
energy
than I did before I don't interesting I
think it might be healthier energy
right like I might be like I drank a lot
of soda
and I drink none now so like I assume
that caffeine and that sugar was driving
me now I'd like to think that it's more
healthy Dynamics but it hasn't shown up
that way it's shown up in fun ways my
son gets tired at a sporting event and
wanted me to carry him from the seat to
the parking lot carrying him while I've
got a bag of like like stuff from the
ball game I didn't have the strength
even when he was a much little little
kid to carry him the whole way whereas
you know I remember I mean bring up this
story because it's very Vivid to me like
four or five years ago I went like the
whole way and I was like oh my God yeah
this is nice to have this strength
because it's also a sweet moment like
when you're a dad your son's sleeping on
your shoulder late night at a game is
like the cutest thing ever something
like I am almost emotional talking about
it right now it's like memory I'll take
to the Grave if I didn't have the
strength to carry him it would have been
a memory I wanted to forget because I
would have been holding his hand while
he was like snickering and complaining
and walking and so
um like at the airport like sit like the
silliest [ __ ] strength right like uh
having my luggage while I can help like
an elderly lady and like I think about
this stuff because yeah I lived without
strength for so long like having a
little more and then like things I think
about like what if God forbid one day in
my life I have to actually use my
strength to stay alive like I'm falling
off a cliff or something I'm like it'll
be cool if I can last six minutes
instead of one minute maybe in that five
minutes somebody will save me like I
think about that [ __ ] yeah me too it
makes you harder to kill that's
literally yeah more resilient more
resilient and I don't think it is silly
strength like the the thing with your
kid or you know putting stuff up at
right and the uh overhead compartment
for an elderly woman yeah these are
things that a lot of people don't think
about it's just general quality of life
and 100 and especially as a father I
don't know personally but I imagine this
is a an extremely important thing as you
mentioned you were getting emotional if
you weren't able to carry your son or be
there for him like to to carry him or
support him
that I imagine that would
wear on you as a father if you're not
able to you know play with them or
whatever I think that's right I think
like you know I genuinely like how it
shows up in the little moments
um and look for me the soft tissue thing
the fascia thing like the quality of
life there's the biggest Delta some of
those are just very nice altruistic
emotional moments the actual quality of
life
of like my back not hurting me or being
discomfort is like real
and it's probably though I talk about
sleeping well
like now literally sitting here like
you know like my quality of sleep has
been better the last six years because
I'm not like adjusting to like you know
discomfort and like not having the
occasional one time a year
where my back would go out it's been
really a lot nice so why do you continue
to work out if you haven't noticed any
measurable differences in in business
like why do you still do it so
consistent well I don't work out for
business I work out because I believe
that 70 to 90. you know Mike once said
something about the correlation of leg
strength and longevity of Life
absolutely and like you know I don't
like take Mike's word for it I'm like is
this some propaganda he's [ __ ] with
me because like these Bulgarian [ __ ]
things are just the worst [ __ ] thing
split squats these bulgarians
Bulgarian splits squats made me I did
two days ago and like I wanted to like
legitimately like kill the world like
they're just so hard and now like you
know they were hard when I had to do
body weight back in the day now this
[ __ ] got me like carrying real
weights with them too so like you know
so I looked into it and it's like really
interesting you start realizing like a
lot of people if they go to a cane or
wheelchair like it really [ __ ] you up
and if you're at 90 and you can still be
walking versus those Alternatives like
that matters and I'm also just very
practical modern medicine like when I
look at everybody here I'm like look at
how awesome we all have it everyone here
has a real shot to be a hundred that was
not the case 30 years ago everybody was
gonna be 85 92. and so like I don't know
like very frankly
I think a lot about being 90 to 100 I
think about who am I going to be at that
point how much wisdom can I like I
always think about like garyvee today is
trying to put out good into the world
and has a big platform well me at 90 to
100 I can be on some Yoda [ __ ] and if I
can hang for another 10 more years I can
leave more positive deposits and if I
have to do [ __ ] Bulgarian split
squats to be there then [ __ ] it I'm
gonna do it I really think that's like
literally exactly how my brain thinks
about it absolutely one another one of
the the biggest correlators to quality
of life as you age is your ability to
get up off the ground correct as you
know if you fall that's right a lot of
that's right elderly people are just
kind of stuck there that's right so
being able to get on the floor like and
then emotional stuff like like
I don't know if I live 90 to 100 does
that mean I get to see my granddaughter
get married versus not like I don't know
like you know it's really funny I think
everyone will associate with this
we all grow up in a way where when
you're 17 you're just not over worried
about being 34. you're like not worried
about 34 year old headaches and then you
get to 34 or 25 and you're like oh [ __ ]
like here I am like right now it's easy
for me not to overthink 90 but like in a
blink I'm gonna be there
and like when you get there then you do
start worrying about it and so like if I
have to put in The Logical work and then
like my friends are like yeah but you
might you know like when they're like
just gorging on food and wine and
they're like I'm not and they're like
yeah but you can get hit by a tree I'm
like yes you can get hit by a tree I
love when people use like mathematical
things that are like virtually
impossible like like as a Counterpoint
like anything you can control if you can
make it better why wouldn't you consider
it and for me working out is the hardest
thing to this day almost a decade later
I do not want to do it it does not come
natural to me it's you know I have such
Envy for people I'm making assumption
just because you're in such great shape
I always feel like for those people it's
kind of like business for me like
business for me comes natural
everything's easy I'll always be great
at it because I've always been and I
always will be
but like
you know I have a lot of envy and I
don't have a lot of Envy in my heart but
I have Envy for people that like
literally like love it can't wait to go
like for me that's not my reality but
it's so damn important I fight for it
love it what was the
so why why hire somebody in person to
travel with you and train you in person
I was self-aware enough to know that
like I would hide like there was there's
this incredible story that Jordan and
Mike talk about where I discovered that
I could put my big toe against my
kitchen against my bathroom counter to
lower the scale weight
and you would do that consciously so
like I also weigh myself every day and I
take a picture and send it to Mike and
Jordan and it's like been kept me in
check it's huge for me
One Day by accident like I like slipped
in the bathroom or something it was an
accident I like slipped in the bathroom
for a second like oh like you know like
kind of scary [ __ ] like there was some
water there it kicked the scale a little
bit I didn't really realize it you know
like showered went on the scale and the
skin was very close to like the bottom
of my sink and just somehow I'm like on
it like somehow it like raised it and I
could see that it kind of moved for a
second I'm like like I'm like literally
just never dawned on me and I was like
wait a minute and so like I pushed it a
little more and I saw the scale went
down
and so I started like nothing happened I
sent them I did the normal day but the
next day I remember this very very like
six years ago I like had a big dinner
and I believe I had a big dinner because
I actually just discovered this thing on
a scale and sure enough the next morning
I was like up more than I'd like to be
and I kicked it a little and then it's
like this went on for like two weeks and
like
and like it completely allowed me to go
up like three actual pounds like
actually not kind of like you know scale
weight and I felt it because at this
point in my life I'd shredded I went
from like 188
to 157
to like 168 but like that 157 to 168
came with like five pounds of muscle and
that was I was like whoa this is
different like you start learning right
I'm like oh I can be like at this weight
but look different I'm like look wait
you know like it's really cool when you
learn like muscle can enter your body
and like reform you and it how much it
hits the scale and you just start
learning when you don't know anything
for all the people who are listening
right now that don't know anything yet
you'll be on this journey
so I really felt it I was like this
sucks like this doesn't feel as good and
so I I it's just this really funny joke
we always have because I was like came
downstairs real sad they were both there
I think if I recall it properly or just
one of them and they zoomed the other
one and I can't remember or face timed
but I was like guys I've lost my way
like it was like real tale between the
leg like I lost my leg I was like
they're like what happened I'm like I
figured this thing out and this and it's
like so it's like you know I guess that
was a very long-winded way to tell you
why I hired somebody full time I knew
that I was gonna try everything and
anything to not do this it's that bad
like it's that hard for me yeah it's
like I'm sitting here right this second
telling you how hard it is and if you
told me nine years later after going
through this journey that it would be
this hard I might have not believed Yoda
said at some point it would have clicked
in it's a fight every day
it's just it's also like be I always
want I actually want to make everyone
who's listening to this make it more
selfish like forget about something as
ideological as Integrity which I think
is such a noble thing to fight for it's
just gonna not be good like there's just
like a much more kind of like basic like
let me make this very basic for you if
you're lying to yourself about anything
it will be bad like like nothing good
will happen in a relationship in like
you know so many kids come up to me like
Garvey you're gonna buy the Jets I'm
gonna buy the Broncos like literally my
brain every time not to like you know
like a lot of times I'm just like man I
hope that kid
doesn't believe that
because because then he's serious about
it correct I mean normally when I say it
my great hope is that they're like
locked in and obsessed and for 40 years
I'm gonna do it but like in reality 99.9
of time it's very obvious to me
immediately that it someone who's
tricking themselves I'm going to be a
billionaire and I'm like why and this
and like there's just like a lot I see
it a lot I'm gonna be a rapper I'm going
to be a professional athlete well you
know why a lot of people do that I'm
sure you know this is we get uh increase
in dopamine when we say we're going to
do something so a lot of people will say
something like that they get that
feeling and then the pursuit of it is it
doesn't matter anymore because they've
already felt what it feels like and so
they just keep saying these things I'm
going to dot dot the danger of the
short-term high in our society is uh is
a real issue and
I know exactly why people do it people
also genuinely
are grounded in insecurity and believe
they can trick people into believing
things
this is a very big thing amongst people
in my opinion when I'm watching people
navigate they're trying to paint a
picture about themselves to others
because they value others opinions of
them
and so the posture they peacock and
um and I think that's a vulnerability
unfortunately when it's not grounded in
actual belief yeah so let's talk about
eating habits please no you love
blueberries yes you mentioned that on
the last episode I do
um what else do you do to I've gotten
knee properly you know I've gotten very
hot on something recently I've
definitely my my carb my bad carb intake
is down and I really feel it which I'm
really excited about I kind of decided
in August after going through a period
of 100 days where I wasn't at my best
which is okay like I think a big thing
for a lot of people is they beat
themselves they go great for six months
they have like one bad week and they're
like ah see it's like it's okay like you
can get back on right so I went through
like a summer where it was just a lot of
travel you know after covid you know I
got to travel a little bit and it just
wasn't as tight as I wanted it to be and
like then I had one week at my parents
house with the family where it really
fell off the wagon because my parents
like just go old school Eastern European
just a lot of garbage and like and
that's an excuse I can navigate around
it but like I was at the tail end of
like a bad hundred day cycle it was
mid-summer we were in the best time
family I just like hit what I would call
my rock bottom of my eating habits and
like really felt shitty about it and
then just kind of
serendipitously watched like a keto
propaganda documentary and I understood
what I was watching but I took certain
elements of it for myself and I kind of
created my own like food triangle of
like I'm gonna go dramatically more
protein because I like it I have a real
it comes unnatural to me but I have a
very good gift on the other side I like
everything
so like I like English peased and
asparagus and cauliflower the same way I
like sugar and a burger and like a shake
like equally so I have this real gift
where I like like it all hmm
so I was like [ __ ] it I love clean
protein I love vegetables like I can
like shift this a little bit and I've
been on it since August and here we are
you know like three four months in and
like you know
I eat a lot of fruits and vegetables I
I'm my carb intake is down that's huge
because I like a good muffin or thing of
that nature
I also try to eat clean more and more so
you know grass finished absolutely not
just grass-fed like how did you mention
that yeah so I'm I'm pretty educated in
some of that stuff like you know my
girlfriend Mona is very educated in it
so like natural flavors I look out for
like I've really become educated on what
the government allows food companies in
America to do and so it's not only about
calorie count it's the it's really now
at this point in my life like organ
meats and things of that nature I've
gotten very very educated and I'm just
fighting to be good about it as often as
possible I'm very relieved that you
mentioned that because that's something
that a lot of people at least in my
experience they don't understand a lot
of it's the next level still focused on
correct calories it's the next level
yeah the next level that our entire
Society is going to go into quality is
the quality of the product uh that comes
along with finances is so I think a lot
about for now correct and so like I
think entrepreneurs are going to get in
there and try to like build good
businesses based on these Trends which
will drive down costs so it's gonna be
fun to watch but like yeah like I
definitely
am really deep on that and I think any
style of eating veganism keto things
that nature anything that goes too
extreme is missing the point so I'm
trying to be very thoughtful of like
being purple like the whole red but you
know like I think a lot about that so
you know I think I'm taking different
little things from different kind of
Trends and knowledge bases but eating
clean like you know glass like even
glass over plastic for water like like
clean is definitely a part of my regimen
I'm not you know just for full
transparency I'm like also very capable
of like just grabbing a Jolly Rancher
and eating it whereas like I know that
is uncomfortably not clean but I
definitely think that I would be in the
category of a clean eater now 80 of the
time which is
insanely exciting for me because to even
just have the knowledge of going to a
restaurant and asking if the beef is
grass finished not just like profound
knowledge base that I didn't have
walking around five years ago and so
I'm really excited about what that will
mean for my longevity yeah speaking of
the knowledge where are you learning all
this stuff Mona okay like she's like
she's very deep into this so she's
propaganding me 24 7. but I'm genuinely
you know curious about it I get into
these Google you know YouTube
documentary and then I'm also very good
at knowing if someone's pushing
something so I'm able to take a little
step back right like you know I I I just
have a very common sense oriented like
you know when I look at
um the personalities on the internet I'm
always trying to understand like hey
what's their objective like what's their
financial goals and I don't begrudge it
you know but I'm also not going to be
like look if I if I just eat this I'm
going to look like that when there's
very clear indications that there's
chemically enhancement going along with
maybe some good behaviors yeah that's
that's why my brand is the captain's
lifestyle because I was a CrossFit coach
for a while people would come to me
asking hey I've been coming to the gym
for a year now why am I not seeing the
difference I would say well how's your
sleep how is your stress levels how is
your diet and their answers would always
be the same you know I'm lucky if I
sleep six hours stress is high because
of relationship work whatever diet is
pretty good and so they're thinking that
they can spend one hour in the gym and
offset the other 23 hours of a bad life
not to mention and you know this the
other thing is a lot of people don't
know what they're doing in the gym for
an hour yeah like I'm like shocked back
to education and I got very fortunate
with Mike and Jordan these are real
dudes everybody get a personal trainer
you know like it's not how they move
yeah it's a big difference
the right way versus the way you want
like my neck tried to do everything at
first
like everything yeah yeah I just didn't
have any strength so like everything was
like the neck was doing all the [ __ ]
like my push-ups for me right and so
like when you learn how to like do it
and just like you know you know this
like dudes are competitive and like do a
lot of things for Optics so like the
amount of ego and the momentum they use
and you're like not doing the right
thing either and then there's also just
like body type like you know like I
definitely for a lot of people listening
like I have a smaller frame and like
smaller natural like I've done so much
of the right stuff what I didn't do Kobe
taught me a big one
I for the first time was able to really
go in on a lot of work in the gym
protein
like I was so obsessed with weight that
I could have a huge lift day and then
fast
and so then what would happen was I
wasn't getting the muscle benefit in
covid because I just had time I was like
you know what [ __ ] it I have the time
let me like see it that was by far the
biggest muscle gain I've ever had so you
know I've definitely been in better
behavior of muscle gain of like okay if
I'm gonna hit it I'm gonna you know I
don't care about what this scale is
going to say today even if I was bad
yesterday like I'm gonna hit the protein
hard after this
um but
some people you're just never going to
look like certain like I talk about this
with entrepreneurship all the time like
like people like Gary want to be like
you I'm like I you're not going to be
like you correct I was like I was
selling stuff at five I've only done
this I'm 40 years in only doing this I
was a natural Talent only doing this
like you're 29 and you were a good
student and worked at a company and
you're starting your first business it's
going to be a gap same for me like I'm
not gonna look like other people that
maybe put in the same amount of work
with me because they've been genetically
predisposed to get different outcomes of
the same work that's okay just maximize
you so what would your advice be to
somebody who is looking at outside
sources like people or they want to grow
keeping up with the Joneses
is the number one way to be an unhappy
person
there we go like keeping like nobody
else's physique nobody else's bank
account nobody else's girl nobody else's
guy nobody else's trips nobody else's
car nobody else's follow count blue
check mark like it's it's never gonna
work out
it's never gonna work out go into your
cocoon
a lot of times I make pretend I was part
of the University of Miami football team
with the rock and like I have to do the
whole team's watching me like I really
have to do this stuff with my head and
like I like that stuff and I want people
to kind of almost live their life that
way like do not live for anybody outside
live for yourself play within your own
cocoon create your own scenarios with
yourself for yourself and very good
outcomes will happen let's talk on this
mindset for a little bit because this is
my number two or maybe number one
performance hack is the story that
you're telling yourself in your head 100
because when most people go to the gym
or do anything hard for that matter they
what if the bad stuff what if I can't do
it what if I fail what if I embarrass
myself in front of all these people I
like to play the game what if the good
stuff what if I could go for a minute
longer what if I could do three more
reps what would it mean about me if I
was able to accomplish this thing comma
I love that it's very beautiful people
comma what about the concept of if you
go to a public gym and you're only doing
15s and somebody snarks at you what
about actually feeling bad for that
person
yeah like to me to me the thought that
somebody would try to hurt your feelings
when you're in the gym
just means they're deeply insecure
deeply
yeah you know and so like I think we as
a society need to start feeling bad for
people that try to make us feel bad like
actually feel bad for them well it's
your whole brand empathy I believe in it
I genuinely have compassion for people
that are trying to hurt me yeah I like
have never reacted to the negativity
thrown at me in anything other than
compassion never no like like because
for me I had to go through
I had to understand because I I used to
be that person I got fortunate let's
remember I'm 47. I didn't start living
my public life until I was like 34. so
many more people all of you are growing
up with it now so I'm sure if I was 18
and started doing the garyvee thing yeah
I was probably a less strong mentally
Supernova though I was still me I would
have probably done well-ish but I would
have succumbed I would have definitely
had insecurities around like who the
[ __ ] that was my zit or you know there
would have been [ __ ] right I can
definitely I can relate to that for me I
got fortunate when this all went down I
was like
on the other side of the hill by then
so I'm curious about the organ Meats do
you actually consume the organ meats or
do you take a supplement I actually
consume that really okay which which
organs I'll eat everything like liver
like I'll eat anything like I'm very
into like livers and brains and hearts
I'm being serious like cow tongue like
I'm I'm very into weird [ __ ] we should
have brought some raw liver yeah like
liver is the easy one for me like liver
is super easy like I like I I like you
know this is less healthy but like I'm
like a foie gras like sea urchin you
know sweet bread anything I'm like very
weird what's the weirdest thing you've
consumed
I think I've had baboon penis I'm
kidding I'm kidding I'm kidding I just
did that for the clip
um but I would like I'm like so weird
like I have I don't skeeve like there's
that Dorian fruit or something that like
kills people yes the super smelly one
yeah I like ate that when I was in Asia
on like CNN like they were like we hear
you I'm like like I'm like I'm very
strange with my tolerance like I saw
this lady like licking like a like an
escalator or something you saw that one
too and I was like embarrassed where my
brain went like I was like I do that
like like it's just like I'm very not
germed I'm like whatever the most
germaphobe oh Howie Mandel I think right
it was like super like I'm the reverse
like which allows me to eat all textures
all theories nothing scares me like I
also grew up in an Eastern European
household uh Soviet where like cow
tongue is a big Delicatessen and it's
like the big ass tongue like it's like
it's not like the little part the whole
[ __ ] things there I would cut the
[ __ ] out of that and eat it with
horseradish like liver was like a
constant my mom would deliver all the
time like yeah that's good yeah it's
really good especially now like now like
I'm really
like really excited that I think
veganism keto this that like I feel like
everyone's going to the middle like I
hope so I really feel it I like really
that's what I do for a living I watch
Trends well that was my favorite part of
our last episode you making the
difference between everybody so blue and
red and we need to come together to form
purple I want it I want it for society
definitely politically but I think we're
even seeing it in health and wellness I
think everyone's like hey this very
alpha male movement hey this maybe more
female energy movement like everyone's
kind of it's coming in and I'm really
excited about it that's my logo it's the
the yin yang I love that that's exactly
right each of these spokes stands for a
different
um most important pillar of of health
and once you understand how to properly
steer I love that about you brother I
think that's a really good stance and I
think that is going to be the answer to
the quiz for the world
whoever can get to the middle
in a sustainable way
forever will be the happiest and so I
think sometimes you get to the middle
through extremes on both sides like I'm
incredibly fiercely competitive I'm very
Alpha you know I call vaynermedia the
honey Empire like Empire is not a soft
word I'm trying to build an Empire but I
want to do it with honey over vinegar
and so I think sometimes you can get to
the middle through extremes which is
okay yeah but actually probably
realistic and self-aware
um but yeah I'm really excited about
health and wellness finding its middle
ground and I hope people get more and
more educated because it's like nice to
live longer and happier
so we've talked about
diet talked about exercise those are the
two things most people are familiar with
what about sleep let's talk about your
sleep habits oh man I sleep my normal is
11
or 12 to 7 at this point for the last I
would argue for the last six years I've
been in the 12 to 7 game now does that I
mean I'm going to
Qatar tonight
like who the hell knows what my sleeping
pattern the next 48 hours is going to be
do you have anybody who helps optimize
like jet lag do you have like a high
performance coach or anything no you
know on that front I haven't gotten to
that place you know what I can tell you
is this
I am
if someone asked me like what's driving
you for all the stuff you put out in the
world
I feel an enormous amount of guilt
for how little anxiety I have
I don't know how else to say it
I in my true purple it is a mixture of
guilt and gratitude
but
it's like tough to talk about publicly
when you know how many of the 8 billion
people on Earth don't have that
I'm so simple
in real life
that I struggle to be anxious and what I
mean by that is nothing bothers me
except
the occasional pop-up of fear that
someone I love is going to get sick or
die soon
and then when that happens
everything else
is just way too manageable
and I feel like the reason I'm talking
about this is I have to believe the fact
that I sleep like a [ __ ] baby
and I mean like really like the second I
lay down it's good night Charlie
Like I Do not sit there and think about
like anything anything yeah it's
you know like why do you think that is
because I don't have anxiety I know but
why because I think I keep life
incredibly uncomfortably simple how so
I don't care about anything except like
20 People's Health like like genuinely
actually for real
nothing I mean I understand I'm just
trying to yeah listeners because like
I'll give you away I'll give you I'll
give you a great example
I think it would
even people that kind of know me well
knock them to their soul when we hang
out in heaven and I show them how much I
cared about my professional career
I have like almost my favorite part of
your book like one of the first
sentences in there like once you truly
understand how unimportant business is
then you can get good 100 brother thank
you for calling that out I have almost
none
of my self-esteem wrapped up in my
professional accomplishments
if I'm on the other side of consuming me
unless I'm like five years in and really
listened to all the words I don't see
how one could get to that conclusion
but it's true
it's all just a game
it's all simple it's all slow for me
it's all easy I love people people can't
hurt me I'm not trickable I believe in
my intuition my emotional intelligence
is off the charts
when people try to hurt me I'm not mad
at them I have compassion for them it's
just all [ __ ]
simple and quiet it really is that
simple it really is that simple now what
even compounds that is I have a heavy
dose of humility in that because I
realize that that is the work of my DNA
and my parenting and my environment all
of which have nothing to do with me
so on top of everything I just said when
you also then
say these things and you come from a
place of humility like one of the
reasons I passionately talk about what I
talk about when it comes to me is I
think I'm giving roses to my parents
when I talk about me in this setting
I don't feel anything good about it I
feel good that my parents get to hear it
and they should feel good about it
they're the creators of
when I talk in any context about myself
that's me giving roses to Sasha and
Tamara vaynerchuk not to me
they built this my mom built this my dad
built this for real now there was
circumstance like but like they decided
to come to America so they even get the
credit for that I mean like they get a
lot of this and so like for me I do have
pride in the way I've built my companies
like when I look at vaynermedia I'm like
I did this of course they my team but
like [ __ ] I did this
but when I talk about me
that's what makes me laugh about people
like kind of like ego or like like I'm
like which is insecurity but like like I
don't know like Michael Jordan
let's talk about it
is that for Michael Jordan or is that
for his parents like like like you know
like like I really think about this [ __ ]
like I think the person that is can talk
about
like their kids can talk about their
businesses their output into society but
you know like it gets hard to like when
I think about my lack of anxiety I'm
like man that was a son of a [ __ ]
[ __ ] masterclass of how to build a
human being my mom gave me
affirmation of confidence on the best
things
held me accountable to things that
didn't matter school but didn't have my
validation wrapped up in it you know how
challenging it is to
punish your child for bad grades make
them realize you just can't [ __ ]
navigate life and do whatever there's
ramifications for certain things when
you're supposed to be doing them but
don't have an ounce of your self-esteem
wrapped up in your dnfs that's [ __ ]
hard
sneak something in before we get out of
here all right
Free Speech free speech
is it being suppressed I don't think so
no no all right
we'll leave it thank you thank you sir
appreciate it